lucas giolio
he's very good he's got good stuff he
lives north south so top of the zone
bottom of the zone fastball up
change up slider down it's a lot easier
for a manager too yes
slash to left and the rise opens the
series with a base hit to left field
and here's josh donaldson
ripped to left field hit well and back
and gone and donaldson jump starts the
twins with a two run first inning home
run that didn't have much launch angle
but he knew it was gone
cruz pops this up
tim makes a call now here comes andrew
vaughan
and there's out number two
on a change up to center
ryan goodwin makes the catch first two
reach first two scores sucks to have
some climbing to do
bottom one ta lead it off
[Music]
get to maeda on for his 12th start his
era up close to five
as you can see 50 strikeouts in 52
innings that's pretty good his control
has been good the last couple of starts
he's starting to get the off speed
pitches over the plate jose abreu has
hit a home run tim anderson hasn't done
much with him that should turn around
here tonight yazmati grandahl has hit
him pretty well
that's ball four a slider that lost its
way and abreu and goodwin have both
walked here in the first inning
three and two
jazz checks his swing and takes a third
straight walk for the sox
to load the bases for zach collins two
and one to collins
zach on the ground very slowly hit and
the only play is on to first the sox
score on a collins rbi groundout
center
and kepler awaits
the twins get a couple give one back
it's 2-1 after one
he still seems to be getting a bit
better
3-2 fastball
popped up left side
t.a makes a catch and one down
target's outside and the pitch is laced
off the glove with mendic into center
field great at bat for kiriloff
not only did it take a while but he got
the payoff at the end
on the ground to third garcia cuts it
off for a chance at two when the sox
turn it
great read by leori garcia
to start the around the horn double play
gavin sheets
comes up to the plate for his very first
major league at batting
and gavin got it out of the way early
the sheets family rejoices and gavin
has his first major league hit on the
second pitch
he's seen
at the bottom of or below the zone
and there it is a strikeout is first
four walks issued by maeda only one hit
in one run and it's a two to one twins
lead
to right field gavin sheets first chance
in right is a good one
and it's a one two three inning for
lucas giolito stocks are down a run as
we go bottom three
the rain is really pelting the field now
time called they're gonna stop play it
really when you say pop-up it really
popped up there's lightning and now yeah
nelson says look you don't really have
to
put it on i mean normally we don't get
the answer of maybe but that's what's
happened here today at guaranteed right
field they're going to unpull the tarp
oh grand doll with a front third base
side
that is the biggest surprise party
you're ever gonna find
bases loaded for the sox once again
and garcia who walked his first time
goes after the first pitch and deposits
it in right for the first lead of the
ball game for the sox a first pitch tear
drop for laori garcia
a rumble of thunder in the distance
and that base hit for nelson cruz andrew
vaughn does a nice job to get that ball
cruz is going for second base that is a
poor decision
in a major way nelson cruz testing
andrew vaughan but andrew got to that
ball easily
got him to chase again
with the slider and it's a one two three
fourth inning that was that quick quick
quick inning he needed
[Applause]
polanco holds there's a good change up
for strikeout number one
it comes in the fifth and one goal
on a line to right gavin sheets makes
the catch and that'll do it for
minnesota's fifth sox are up or run in
the series opener and now another
opportunity for gavin sheets
he goes after the pitch and pops it
third base side donaldson isn't gonna
get there
here comes a iran
colin scores
born to third
gavin sheets of parachute rbi
they're going to be in much better shape
going forward
into center field
kepler in mid-center vaughan takes off
kepler's throw to the plate is laid
andrew vaughan
gives garcia a sac fly and the sox have
a second run in the inning mendic oh for
two
to center field on a line danny mendick
sheets around third kepler gives it all
and misses by a mile
it is six to two
sox here in the fifth tim wants to add
to that lead
smoked
off the glove of polanco
and here comes mendic ta
a line drive
seven to two
[Applause]
and the twin saw a few change-ups with
gia lito on the mound they'll see a few
with marshall on the mound as well
it's down the line and cruz has another
hit to the corner this time it gets to
the wall larnick will score
and cruz gets to second base
and it's 7-3
kepler drives it to center going back is
good one still chasing it and it's over
his head it'll be another extra base
head crews will try to score
and the twins open the inning with three
straight doubles really big at bat here
for kirill off now
on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is kepler and now the tying run 90 feet
away two out for kirilov
in the air center field billy hamilton
ends the tension in the sox win